[Music]
summer 2019's almost upon us and with it
comes a slew of exciting anime shows for
everyone to enjoy this year's been a
strong year when it comes to smash hit
anime will 2019 summer match up to the
previous season's runs we can only wait
and see
we start off the list with bem at number
10.
bim's a unique case as it's a show
that's the second remake of a 1960s
anime with this one being for the
franchise's 50th anniversary i guess
this is the year of 1960s anime remakes
huh i mean we had dora road just now as
well the old super
[Music]
at number nine we have astra lost in
space
kenta shinohara otherwise known for his
best-selling title sket dance tries his
hand at sci-fi with astra lost in space
this story is set in a distant future
where space travels integrated with
everyday life for nine children on their
way to a planetary camp one fated trip
is anything but ordinary as they
encounter a light sphere that transports
them to an unknown planet the catch they
have to travel five thousand and twelve
light years to get back home despite the
sci-fi tank being associated with mecca
space drama and a lot of battles astra
lost in space is a sci-fi series that
doesn't have a lot of combat but what it
lacks in battles that most shonen jump
titles take pride in it makes up for
with a healthy dose of mystery and space
adventures let's come together to see
what adventures await the nine children
on their journey home
[Music]
eighth on this list is seven seeds
this anime takes place in the immediate
future where a giant meteorites collided
with earth and wiped out all living
organisms including mankind the
government had foreseen this so they
took measures to counter the worst case
scenario in particular was the project
seven seeds in which five sets of seven
young men and women were carefully
selected and placed into teams each
participant was then put under cryogenic
sleep in the hopes of preserving the
continued existence of mankind they'd be
released once conditions on earth had
become safe enough for them to live in
now the story begins in an unknown
number of years in the future when one
of the team awakens and learns that
their entire world and old life has been
destroyed and evolution has begun anew
if you're looking for a survival
adventure series with romance and
psychological aspects you should
definitely check this one out when it
hits netflix by the end of this month
danmachi's much awaited second season's
finally here and it takes the seventh
spot on the list
for the lower ones who prayed to the
gods for a continuation of belle's
journey with the hestia familia wait no
more it only took four years a multitude
of spin-offs ovas and a movie but fear
not for belle crannell and the rest of
the danmachi cast are here once more and
they're ready to take on whatever comes
their way this time group warfare takes
center stage in the war games proxy wars
that pit familias against each other
with the winner taking or at the end of
this arc the decisive collision with the
soma familia awaits bell and the hestia
familia will stop at nothing for victory
but so do their opponents with our
heroes overcome the biggest challenge
yet be sure to stay tuned as danmachi
returns this july
[Applause]
chinese hit king's avatar storms in at
number six with its anticipated second
season
not too long ago king's avatar took the
anime world by storm among the numerous
series that deal with video games rarely
do you see something focused on esports
with the narrative that today's youth
can really relate to king's avatar
captivated numerous anime fans and
aspiring pro gamers it's truly a fresh
change of pace to see amidst all those
stories that involve the characters
being transported into game worlds this
time we should expect a tournament arc
where yishu attempts to lead his new
team team happy to greater heights
expect a lot of exciting action and
drama as the team joins the challenger
league this second season should not
disappoint
at number five we have the much-awaited
ari furita
they sure kept everyone waiting for this
one didn't they after numerous delays
due to production issues it's finally
time for the anime community to witness
hajime nagumo's one-way trip to the
fantasy world if there are any
indications that the isikai train isn't
stopping anytime soon this show is
definitely one of them ari ferreta joins
the ranks of seasonal istakai that
features a weak and bullied character
who eventually rises and goes from
commonplace to the world's strongest
this time though ari furetta looks to
rise above the rest of its kin with its
darker tone and anti-hero main character
we'll see where white fox will go with
this adaptation of the hit light novel
fans of light novel adaptations
featuring overpowered main characters
and the harems shouldn't pass this one
up
fan favorite accelerator stars as the
fourth anime on the list a certain
scientific accelerator
right after we thought that was it for a
certain magical index jc staff comes at
us again with a spin-off starring one of
the franchise's most popular characters
the level 5 esper accelerator as he
continues his recovery at the hospital
accelerator enjoys a relatively peaceful
life a far cry from where we saw him in
index it all changes when he meets a
mysterious girl who has connections with
the last order the ride just doesn't end
for index fans though this time a
spin-off featuring the cool accelerators
something that you might want to check
out do take note though that the
experience is more complete if you've
already watched at least the first
season of index so what are you waiting
for start your own adventure into
academy city and the index series now
[Music]
just when you think you've seen it all
here comes fire force at number three
fire force brings us to a world where a
phenomenon known as spontaneous human
combustion turns humans into infernals
charcoal-like beings that spread death
and destruction
standing against the rampage of those
monsters is the special fire force a
group of trained individuals that have
the ability to harness the flames within
themselves however there's more than
meets the eye to these burning
monstrosities as shinra soon begins to
discover the truth behind the infernals
and the mysterious fire that killed his
family i've got to say soul eater's
writer atsushi okobo showcases his
creativity with the many unique powers
featured in the series with such an
engaging manga one can't help but be
excited for the anime series featuring
literal fire fighters the best part is
that the show seems to be in good hands
if the trailers are any indication to go
by for those craving more soul eater
black clover and similar fare this might
be the show for you
[Music]
shonen jumps dr stone takes second place
on the list
a bright light appears in the sky one
day and engulfs the world turning
everyone to stone and effectively
putting an end to civilization as we
know it high schooler taiji oki is among
the people consumed and turned into
stone but through sheer willpower he
manages to keep himself alive thousands
of years later awakening to a world of
statues taiji soon finds out that his
science enthusiast friend senku ishigami
also managed to escape petrification now
a new goal presents itself in front of
the two friends with their complimentary
talents they'll begin to rebuild
civilization from zero we've seen the
fallout of the world ending so many
times in anime already but the medium
just keeps throwing surprise after
surprise at us coming from someone who
hasn't read the manga dr stone really
does look quite interesting
survival in a primitive world story is
not something that you see every day and
i'm extremely interested in seeing how
this narrative actually plays out dr
stone rightfully takes his place among
the most anticipated series in this
upcoming season
[Music]
and at the top of this list we have
vinland saga the adaptation of makoto
yukimura's manga proudly takes the crown
of the number one most anticipated anime
of summer 2019. finland saga revolves
around the story of toffee and torson an
icelandic warrior driven by the fire of
vengeance against his father's killer
looking to exact revenge tawfin joins
the viking group of asgalad his father's
very killer with the promise of a future
duel against the person he swore
vengeance to
besides its brutal battles finland saga
also takes some cues from history and is
actually quite educational could this be
the start of a resurgence for historical
fiction only time will tell what we know
is that witch studios will have their
hands formed whether vin land saga could
replicate the magic of attack on titan
for which remains to be seen but as far
as we're concerned the hype is off the
charts especially for anime fans in the
west
[Music]
all in all summer 2019 looks to be
packed with shows for all kinds of
tastes i'm pretty sure that whatever
genre you enjoy you could find something
to look forward to any other shows that
you're excited for if so let us know
we'd love to hear from you so comment
below and like the video if you did and
subscribe for more anime related content
we also finally made it to 500k
subscribers yes thanks to everyone who
subscribed especially those who kept
supporting the channel even after the
changing content thank you so much your
support definitely definitely means a
lot i'll see you next time on vini tube
[Music]
you